hi
my name is paul matthews i'm an
investigator and co-director of the
neurotherapeutics group at lundqvist
institute for biomedical information i'm
also an assistant professor in the
department of neurology at the
university of california los angeles
i
appreciate i appreciate the
invitation to speak today at the lab
roots neuroscience conference
and i am excited to tell you about a
novel a tactic mouse model of ataxia
telangentasia caused by a clinically
relevant nonsense mutation that we've
been working on in the lab
now ataxia telling dictation is not only
a mouthful to say but it's also a
horrible disease it's rare it's a
multi-system disorder uh occurs in about
one in one hundred thousand individuals
the telongic tasia
is basically bloodshot eyes or
vasoconstriction of
blood vessels and this differentiates it
from many other types of ataxia the
ataxia is a loss of motor coordination
that is
rises from a neurodegeneration in
particularly the selective
neurodegeneration in the cerebellum you
can see here at five-year-old in a
five-year-old patient that that bottom
area there uh
in between the two arrows nice
relatively healthy cerebellum but it 13
years there's a lot of loss of tissue
and dysfunction of the cells within that
brain region and that gives rise to this
loss of motor coordination as the
cerebellum is a major center that is
involved in this type of behavior
as i said it's a multi-system disorder
there are many other characteristic
symptoms of the disease including
radiosensitivity
high predilection
so immune defects they're
immunosuppressed a high predilection
towards cancers and particular lymphatic
types of cancers and patients are
usually sterile
the progression of the disease well
usually parents begin to identify
challenges
in their children around one or two
years of age when
the
at children
are unable to
progress across their milestones in
particular that of moving from the
toddling stage as you see here into a
coordinated uh walk
unfortunately it's a progressive
disorder and that is that while the
patients are able to walk
and there's
not a lot of changes up till five years
of age the motor coordination does begin
to progressively decline
patients are usually in wheelchairs by
their early teens
and unfortunately patients die
between the ages of 10 and 30 years of
age about a third from respiratory tract
infections a third from cancer and then
a third from major complications of the
ataxia itself as eating and swallowing
becomes
particularly affected
at a genetic disorder it's an autosomal
recessive disorder that is is that both
parents must carry at least one copy of
the abnormal gene and this means that at
patients are children who have
defects uh in the ataxia telegectasia
mutated gene um which is shown here and
it's abbreviated as atm
several different mutations have been
identified over a hundred um and this
includes nonsense missense deletions and
frame shifts that cause disruption of
the atm gene
leading to the loss of function of the
atm protein
the atm protein is a serine threonine
protein kinase it's a huge protein over
3000 amino acids has several signaling
domains
and given all of this complexity it has
also been in implicated in a wide host
of different
cellular processes this includes those
from neurotransmitter release to
mitochondrial metabolism
autophagy
metabolism within glucose uptake it's
most well known for its role in dna
repair in particular
in restoring or in
initiating the repair of double-stranded
breaks to dna
and has also been implicated in gene
regulation so as you can imagine loss of
a protein with such a diverse set of
roles
is likely to cause a very diverse set of
characteristics symptomology
and unfortunately at this time there are
no therapeutics or cures that exist care
is generally
generally palliative and the outlook for
these patients is unfortunately bleak
the ataxia itself is the most penetrant
aspect of the disease while the cancer
and the
immune defects and infections that occur
are diverse across the patient
population they all
eventually
are attack gain ataxia
and it
it is the one symptom that has the
greatest impact on their quality of life
severely limiting it putting them in a
wheelchair putting them bed bound um and
eventually causing death
the link between atm deficiency and
cerebellar ataxia is
clear what the deficiency in the atm
protein does that specifically leads to
a cerebellar degeneration and
dysfunction
and um
what we've done recently is to create a
new clinically relevant mouse model of
at
this mouse model has
a nonsense mutation that is that causes
a premature termination codon
in particular we inserted
a
mutation at
codon 103
that changed the c to a t and in humans
this causes an r35x mutation in mice
because the
gene is a little different there it
causes a q35x mutation as we've shown
here on the left
this mutation is
uh is found in a large patient
population in northern africa
the mutation this nonsense mutation
causes complete loss of the atm protein
as you can see over here on the right in
the western block
across the top rows there you can see
these black lines each of those black
lines is indicative of how much atm
protein is in the mouse and as you can
see the r35x
homozygotes do not have any atm protein
while there is a gene dose risk response
in those that have at least one wild
type copy of the gene you know which you
can see in the middle
lane
unfortunately
um we hit a major roadblock and quite
honestly it wasn't unexpected and the
challenge is is that atm deficient mice
do not develop ataxia of course if we
want to understand the link between atm
deficiency and that of
ataxia in particular the mechanisms that
are
leading to defects in the cerebellum
then we need a model that also
replicates or recapitulates this
uh to give you just an an illustration
of this
i will show you a video of two mice on a
vertical pole on the left is a wild type
and on the right is a completely atm
deficient mouse these mice are 400 days
age old
and
you will see that there's really no
difference in their motor coordination
skills
at this age
so you could see that both mice were
fully capable of walking down the pole
there was no problem
this is not a unique feature of
mouse models of
atm deficiency
several other
mouse models have been examined um that
are deficient in other dna repair
pathway proteins this includes the
proteins after toxins cenataxon mre 11
and tdp-1
and
while in humans loss of any loss of
expression of any of these proteins
causes a toxic phenotype in mice it does
not
here we're showing just an example of
this so this is a on the left a wild
type mouse and on the right is an
apritaxin or aptx knockout mouse and
you'll see that both mice are capable of
walking down the pole without any issue
the aptx mouse is a little bit slower
but
overall they don't show any
defects in their motor coordination
so what we decided to do was to try to
increase the genotoxic stress if the
reason that the mice were
were able to overcome the loss of these
dna repair pathway proteins maybe it's
that their shorter lived lives
allow for them to accommodate the loss
of any one of these proteins and so what
we
tested was the potential of crossing
single mutant atm
r35x so these are atm knockout mice with
a nonsense mutation with that of an aptx
knockout mouse to create a double mutant
that was deficient in both atm as well
as aptx to see whether
loss of multiple proteins in this
dna repair pathway
pathways would induce an attack
phenotype and indeed that's what we
found
here you can see two mice the mouse on
the left is a wild type uh well is a
wild type atm
on an aptx knockout background
and it's normal walks no problem and
you'll see on the right that there's a
severe ataxia at 400 days in the double
mutant mouse lacking both atm and aptx
expression
as you can see this is not a mild
phenotype this is a mouse that has
severe
deficits in its ability to coordinate
its its limbs
we
find behavioral deficits in these mice
as early as postnatal day 8 p8
using a
postnatal writing reflex
experimental paradigm in which the mice
are just laid the little pups are laid
on their back and we time them to see
how long it takes them to flip over
this is um in normal mice takes
relatively little time a couple of
seconds and they're able to do it
quickly however we found in both male
and female mice
a
longer time to flip over and coordinate
this
reflexive movement
in general
at it
is not found to have differences between
males and females and across our
examination of the mice we also did not
identify any sex differences in the
animal populations and in many cases we
you'll see that we have combined
our
data across both male and female
the
however after p8 the mice do
grow
and
show relatively normal motor
coordination
at p30 we've assessed them in multiple
behaviors including the vertical pole
essay that you saw above and it's not
until 200 days
after 200 days that the mice really
begin to show a deficit or a progressive
decline in their motor coordination and
this is somewhat similar to that of at
patients in which
an initial assessment or identification
of an inability to progressive
to progress from the sort of toddling to
the correct
and coordinated walking stages
patients normally patients usually don't
show a major dramatic change in their
motor coordination up until age five or
so even though they've got some deficits
in which then there's usually a dramatic
progression um and decline in motor
deficit and so we see that here as well
although in this case it happens after
postnatal day 200.
and here i'll show you just how dramatic
that is you saw how poor the mouse
was able to just move around as it was
on a flat surface and if we put them on
the
vertical pole you can see that there's a
significant reduction in their ability
to climb down and of course we didn't
put them all the way up at the top
given their
real severe loss of motor coordination
although they are able to to move down
small sections of it although very
slowly
as you can see this is not a mild
deficit this is a severe loss of motor
coordination
that progresses after postnatal day 200.
we examined further the mouse's
behaviors on a battery of different
behavioral tests which i've shown here
along the left are the names of the
different behavioral tests that we
examined mice at both postnatal day 30
and postnatal day 400
in the purplish dark
side on the left are the wild type and
on the right are
the double
at mutants and as you can see
there aren't a lot of deficits that we
can really detect
at postnatal day 30 although we do see
maybe a
deficit on the body position and one can
read this graph just by looking at the
difference in the the length of the bars
left to right and then the blue is male
and the pink is female
at 400 days we see a number of defects
in the animals
those that you could see just visually
and those that we could measure as well
most of which are related to
motor
aspects of behavior
so we next wanted to understand if this
loss of motor coordination how
the
cerebellum was impacted in this so of
course the
in at patients there is a degeneration
or an atrophy of the cerebellum so we
look to see whether there was an atrophy
in these mice as well
and we did indeed find a developmental
loss of
the of cerebellar tissue in these mice
we looked at and
the ratio of the area of the cerebellum
to that of the forebrain in order to
normalize it to potential differences
just an overall brain size
and you can see that we see a
significant drop in the size of the
cerebellum at p200 that continues on a
little bit through
and past p400
i'm showing you here a number of
different genotypes that have different
amounts of either atm or aptx
the purple being that of the wild type
and then the orange
being that of the double mutant an
expression of at least one copy of the
atm
um or the aptx
gene although i'm not showing that one
here
uh is sufficient to alleviate the
symptomology in these mice and this is
suggests that if one was able to restore
some of the atm protein
that would probably have a major effect
on these mice
we next wanted to look at the
what it was that was atrophying within
the cerebellum and we took a look at
the cortex of the cerebellum in
particular we measured the molecular
layer and granule cell layer
of the
cerebellar cortex the molecular layer
containing the purkinje neuron dendrites
which is a primary cell within
the cerebellar cortex and what we found
was that there in
we found in the wild type mouse uh no
change in the molecular layer width
across age however we did find a
significant
reduction in the
prekenji neuron in the parking neuron
dendritic layer that molecular layer
over time and we found these effects
across both the medial intermediate and
lateral areas of the cerebellum
we did not find any change in the
granule cell layer suggesting that there
is a relatively selective effect going
on within the purkinje neurons in
[Music]
the cerebellum and so we decided to take
a closer look to see whether there were
physiological disruptions that were also
going on within the purkinje neurons
to do this we examined uh the
electrophysiological the properties of
bricking neurons here we looked at their
neural
their neural signaling that is their act
the action potential that purkinje
neurons generate spontaneously
they're a little bit different than most
other neurons that they will fire these
action potentials at 40 to 120 hertz
without any excitation
we did this by taking acute slices of
the brain having them
incubated in an artificial cerebral
spinal fluid and then just took an all
an extra cellular electrode right up
next to the fricking neuron and recorded
the electrical impulses which you can
see in this purple and orange traces on
the right here
in the wild type on the top you can see
that there's a fast set of action
potentials each of those vertical lines
is an action potential and that the rate
of these action potentials is
significantly decreased in the double
mutant
we found that this was developmentally
regulated although we found
across the different regions the lateral
intermediate and medial
that the
firing rate was reduced as early as um
p45 postnatal day 45 and that it did
reduce um significantly down at
postnatal day 200
into p400
and that
expression of either atm or aptx was
sufficient to alleviate
this phenotype
to prevent this phenotype
we then took a closer look to see what
some of the biophysical properties were
of the pretend neurons that might be
disrupted and that could give rise to
these changes in the neural signaling
properties of burkini neurons that that
output signal of the king neurons
and so again we did um recordings in
acute slices in this case we're doing
whole cell patch recordings
using a voltage clamp method and we can
then it use voltage steps to
create current changes in the cell and
identify and examine specific
membrane properties in particular we
looked at the membrane resistance the
membrane time constant and the membrane
capacitance we found abnormal
differences in the double mutant mice
across all three of these metrics and in
particular we did find almost a half
half the membrane capacitance in the
double mutant mice
and this means that the
double mutant mouse purkinje neurons are
likely about have half the membrane of
that of the of the wild type and this is
consistent with a shrinking of the
pretense neurons um that would be
consistent with the shrinking of the
molecular layer with the ricking neuron
dendrites and a predominant amount of
their membrane is composed
we then also looked at synaptic inputs
into the purkinje neurons to look to see
whether there was maybe dysregulation of
other cells within the
in
the cerebellar cortex and consistent
with the fact that the
granule cell layer didn't show any um
loss in their width we didn't find any
uh
defects in the synaptic inputs of uh the
granule cells to the purkinje neurons
here we looked at the mini excitatory
postsynaptic currents these are the
currents that are just generated
spontaneously from the granule cell
parallel fiber synaptic endings onto the
kidney neurons
and there are two traces here that you
can see at the top one in purple and one
in orange
we didn't find any differences in the
amplitude the average amplitude of the
currents and this suggests that
the
granule cells are not showing any
perturbations we did however find a
difference in the frequency and this
would suggest that there are actually
twice as many granule cell inputs onto
the purkinje neurons and this is an
interesting finding that we hope to
further investigate in the future
we also looked at the paired pulse
facilitation which is a normal response
of parallel fibers so this is a
short-term
form of plasticity if you stimulate the
parallel fibers twice in short
succession in this case just 50
milliseconds
the second pulse the second current
response is usually larger than the
first and we found no difference in
the paired pulse facilitation in the
granule cell
parallel fiber inputs onto the prequel
neurons which further supports the idea
that the granular cell synapoxide that
pre-synapse in the granule cells was
normal
we did however find some abnormal
uh inputs from the climbing fiber which
is the other major input into the
prekinder neurons and these differences
suggest defects in the intrinsic calcium
currents within the pretense neurons
the in the case of climbing fibers
instead of paired pulse
facilitation
one normally finds paired pulse
depression that is that the second
current response to a double
uh stimulation of the axons the climbing
fibers results in a smaller current
response rather than a larger one
and you can see that in the double
mutant mice the
size of that second response is even
smaller than that of the
the wild type we also we did however
find that the overall amplitude of what
is really an all or none synaptic input
from the climbing fibers was not
different between the
wild type and double mutants and this
suggests that the climbing fiber synap
presynaptic side is normal however we
did find significant differences in both
the half width the with
the half width and the decay rate of the
current
in the
climbing fibers and this suggests that
there's actually an intrinsic um
challenge
in the calcium currents within the
in the purkinje neurons
as these that the currents that are
recorded are predominantly mediated
by calcium flux
these mice
showed other characteristic
uh
symptoms of at they showed reduced
weight and survivability and they also
showed a high uh pride election and
predisposition for cancer
here i'm just showing the weight of the
animals over age and you can see that in
the male the
double mutants are about half the weight
by p 200 and in females they're about a
third they're about two-thirds the
weight of the
control mice
any mouse that lacks atm at all whether
whether or not there is any aptx showed
reduced survivability that is that they
had predisposition in this case for
cancer
we in these pie charts here you can see
that
the bottom three on the right there
which are all of the atm deficient mice
with no with all some or no aptx all had
a high preponderance in the bluish gray
for developing
a
thymoma
cancer in the thymus and that in large
part these
um thymomas were responsible for
the
50 survival rate of the mice that you
can see over on the left and the
probability of survival in mice that
lack the atm protein
these mice also show immune defects
which i'm not going to talk about or
tell you show you any data on today but
they these mice
for the first time
show the broad spectrum of
characteristic symptoms of at and thus
provide us for the first time a mouse
model to not only examine
the underlying mechanisms that link atm
deficiency and aptx deficiency
to cerebellar dysfunction and atrophy
but also as a potential tool
to test therapeutic approaches
and
understand whether any potential
therapies might have any therapeutic
efficacy and as of such right now
a major challenge within
the development of at therapies has in
part been that there's been no animal
model with which to really test them
before it gets um to the clinic
so in conclusion um as i stated here
just now um our novel mouse model of at
um
mouse model of at deficient mice and
that lack both atm and aptx
develop a progressive and severe ataxia
the ataxia is associated with cerebellar
atrophy resulting from progressive
shrinkage of the dendritic length of the
purkinje neurons and that the attacks is
also associated with abnormal neural
activity and membrane properties of the
praking neurons
the synaptic inputs to prekinder neurons
appear relatively normal but its
response properties suggest defects in
the intrinsic calcium currents and or
homeostasis within pretense neurons
in the future we're hoping to expand the
analysis of the contributors to the
cerebellar atrophy to see whether
other cells not just the granule cells
and the parking neurons may
not just the pretending neurons are
affected it looks like the granule cells
which is the most predominant cell type
in the cerebellar cortex a purifying
we hope we will plan to look at the
cerebellar nuclei as well as
non-neuronal types of cells glia et
cetera like the bergming glia
we plan to further define the abnormal
forking neuron properties and their
implications on disrupting cerebellar
output and those effects on control of
motor coordination because of course the
underlying ataxia here is unlikely
generated by
significant loss of purkinje neurons as
it doesn't look like they
are dying off but that they are
dysfunctional and that this dysfunction
is changing the neural activity and
output of the cerebellum which is likely
contributing to the
the motor defects and finally we look to
elucidate the link between why dna
repair pathway proteins like atm and
aptx when deficient in mice uh
when deficient in mice and humans causes
cerebellar defects and atrophy and
resulting in ataxia
i'd like to thank the a
number of people who have contributed to
this project
in particular those
past and present who have worked in my
lab this includes harvey may jose martin
kim callum genie and angelina
and several of my
collaborators
uh most notably tim madrenas and
michelan
and i'd like to thank my funders
including the nints the lundquist
institute and the ctsi at ucla thank you
for taking the time to listen to my talk
and
i hope to hear from you soon if you have
any questions